awesome thank you very much for being
here today it's making it to the last
talk of the conference or the closing
keynote which I will now put that in my
trip report at work and tell my boss so
thank you talk today talk today's on the
future of machine learning and the
JavaScript my name is Asim Hussain you
could find me on twitter as draw eight
not joash a draw eight my blog about
angular and javascript and very very
soon I'll have more content on machine
learning on my website code Croft TV and
also soon to be awesome dev yes I bought
it and I am a cloud developer advocate
at Microsoft
I'm actually the Emil lead for cloud
developer advocacy at Microsoft thank
you very much recent promotion thank you
thank you thank you and we are the curse
we we work on the agile platform we are
the open source advocates on Asia which
is our cloud platform to go to my link
there you can find all of us you can
find all of our contact details on it's
an old one smiler I don't have you on
this table sorry I apologize you can go
and find us we have people who
specialize in all different technologies
on the other our contact details there I
also work with an Israeli charity called
pal internship and what they do is they
work with Palestinian recent graduates
and they help them get internships in
high tech Israeli companies I mentored
thank you I mentored about 10 of them
last year and I'm very proud to say that
this year 17 but all the tech cohort
will have a mentor will be one of the
cloud advocates at Microsoft so if you
are or you work at an Israeli high tech
firm and you have openings or
availability for an intern go to that
website come speak to me I can connect
you with Anna who is the program
director
thank you I also am an instructor on a
platform called udemy let me know udemy
okay they recently added in subtitling
to the platform and they correctly
transcribed my name too awesome
so my name is awesome but like this
slide this next site probably sums up me
over the last year so this is not this
is not my slide actually this I've
stolen this from my friend Ellen her
slide Ellen and I go back a long way and
we both in to me were both into machine
learning were both into JavaScript and
so earlier on last year we decided to
start our own meetup group in London
called AI JavaScript London and then
we've held quite a few meetups over the
course of the year and what happens is
during the course these meetups and just
afterwards people will come up to us and
give us links to hey did you know that
this cool JavaScript application uses oh
this one and so we thought okay
fantastic let's get all those links
together put it online somewhere and
that's what we did we made a website
called a ijs rocks it would have been a
ijs dev you know if we'd wait a little
bit but say I chose rocks and if you go
there it's got a whole collection of
JavaScript powered a I powered
JavaScript applications which all
represent and show a way of doing AI in
JavaScript what's really cool about it
is this JavaScript so you can always
click on all of them find out how it
works but then you can also click on the
source you can click on the source code
figure out how they were built and
hopefully learn a little bit about how
to do machine learning and AI and what
today's talk is going to be but as I'm
going to talk to you about machine
learning and AI in Java by talking my
way through three different applications
that are on the website okay and explain
how those applications were built and
through that whole process today I'm
going to teach
a little bit more about machine learning
until the end you're going to know a
hell of a lot about machine learning I
guarantee it okay
the first one is the moji fire this is
my application I built this one it's not
trademarked it's just the moji fire so
made sense and what the moji fire does
is it does something for something
amazing
so what it does is you can give it a
picture with some faces it then detects
the faces in the picture it then detects
the the emotion in the face and then any
guesses
it modifies it correct
excellent so it finds the correct emoji
to match the emotion and places on the
face okay that's exactly what the mojo
fire does actually released it as a
slack box you can actually go to the
Mojo fire calm hit add to slack and
it'll be added to any of your slack
workspaces it works like this so this is
my son by the way isn't he cute you add
/mo g phi add it in correct emotion as
it to the face it works with multiple
faces so you can get that one and add it
in here we go I've managed to anse an
age-old question which has plagued
people for hundreds of years and
multiple different moving parts in this
application but I think one of most
interesting parts of what it does is how
does it calculate emotion right that's
crazy right how does it calculate
emotion on a face but it's actually
really simple it's really simple it's
only got two steps okay the first step
is detecting facial features so what are
the different now over all these years
we now are aware of quite a few known
facial features which every single face
has got and if we can detect exactly
where they are that's a step one this
different algorithms to make that happen
lots of different computer vision
algorithms it doesn't necessarily need
to use machine learning to do it and
that you can find a whole bunch of
information now there's loads of
different jobs with libraries which can
give you the facial features given an
image okay that's step one you just need
the facial features okay step two really
simple you're just using your network
okay now we all know how to use neural
networks
in this yeah okay okay I'll explain your
networks really briefly just to the rest
of you so neural network is based upon
real biological concepts ok real
biological concepts so this is a neuron
you have at least one of these in your
head you probably have several million
less than you did this time yesterday
you have some dendrites going in a body
and some axons are going out if enough
electricity flows into the dendrites the
body triggers some electricity to go out
of the axons that's it that's it if you
stick enough for these together you get
a brain I think there's a little bit
more to consciousness than just neurons
but teach their own code this up using
some language probably JavaScript you
probably all know kind of how to start
off with this process you just kind of
graph theory a little bit so you have
some edges going in a node and an edge
going out you would then perhaps feed
into the edges some features okay maybe
that feature is number of coffee shops
in an area and the house price increase
per years an actual study done in London
is directly proportional to coffee shops
and that those might be some features
you feed into your new neuron and then
what you do with the edges you just have
a random number you randomize it we give
a random number to each edge you
multiply them together and you add them
up and then you pass that into an
activation function and whatever that
activation function returns you pumped
out that's like the electricity coming
in and the electricity going out that's
all it is just explain it a little bit
more detail watch the screen
boom this is it right you're just
multiplying these two numbers together
adding them up passing through an
activation function and passing out
that's it that's right when I teach
machine learning in a workshop some
people off halfway through like it's
just it's just multiplication that's all
it's just multiplication right it's just
lots and lots and some addition that's
mainly a large part of what what forms
it right you have loads of different
activation functions no choice of an
activation function it just like you
have to understand the data and
understand what's going on but it's
those different ones this is a very very
simple one anything below zero is zero
anything above zero is one and that's
the one used there you join enough of
them together this is what we call a
simple feed for or densely connected
feed for neural network so we have one
input layer one output layer two hidden
layers and it's just the same stuff just
what I showed you before just those
neurons connected together
you just create a bunch of nodes a bunch
of edges you randomized a bunch of
numbers to be the weights math but
random it is not random yeah math dot
random and there you goes in your
network and then what you do you get
your data set your training data set
that might be a bunch of images a bunch
of images that you already know this is
a happy images of sad image you already
know that you get the facial features
whatever they are you pumped them in as
the input notes
that's what there's maybe that maybe the
X Y coordinates of a pupil or the
relative distances into cute people
something along those lines you multiply
that's what we're doing he remember
multiplication whose multiply it all
together and you look at what it outputs
but because you have
I have a spare slide yeah but because so
this neural network gave us three but we
know because we know this is a happy
face maybe maybe ten is happy and zero
is sad we know that this is eight we
labeled their human being said that's
actually an eight so we know that this
neural networks wrong it's wrong by five
five it's wrong by five so what we want
to do is we need to that's what we call
the loss function because that's what we
call we know how far how wrong is this
neural network right now it's probably
very very wrong because it was a random
math dot random so it's probably very
very wrong and then what we do is
something called back propagation which
given how wrong it is we tune these
weights these weights that originally
random we tune them we adjust them ever
so slightly and we keep on doing that
you pass through the data again and
again the game figures that how long is
hopefully the wrongness becomes less and
you tune it closer and closer and close
and all you're doing is adjusting tuning
those numbers so that eventually then
you're on that what gives you the data
that you wanted I think you can give it
a new image I never just never ever seen
before and you pumps all this stuff
through and it gives you the value of
happiness or sadness or something along
those lines what you can do then is you
can just basically save this data and
either kind of wrap it in some sort of
API put it on a server and then make a
call pass an image to it make a call and
come back right you can do that the
usually can be quite large maybe don't
run this locally on your computer it
depends it depends right you can do that
but these kind of problems are actually
really really common believe it or not
right under seige your feature
recognition emotional recognition is
something that you solved many many
times before and then what you do and
what companies like my company does is
we basically make it available urinate
it's your face API I'm I've actually put
a request in to have this image changed
cuz I think she looks very confused I
don't think we should have an image of
somebody looking confused on a marketing
material but I use for the mojo fire is
the face API it's does everything that
we've just described has been done this
we made available just for your an API
you pass an image to the API and it
gives you an array one for each face it
detects so gives you the rectangle
because you remember means put an emoji
own image
and it gives you emotions from 0 to 1
for anger contempt disgust fear
happiness mutual sadness and surprise
hands up if you have a bid I can see you
a couple of us yes you cannot be 100%
happy I've tried you can only ever get
to 99% happiness ok just warning that's
it that's how the keep up how I built
the Mojo fire key takeaway neural
networks incredibly powerful we look at
the step jump that's been happening in
machine learning over the last five six
years it's been doing a lot by stuff is
going on with your networks new
algorithms compute that is working in
the space especially deep neural
networks they're really powerful but
conceptually they're quite simple to
understand now in this five ten minutes
I probably explain to you the basics the
very very basics of a neural network ok
did you get much more complicated than
that you're not gonna all be able to go
away now and get a job as a machine
learning engineer ok it does get more
complicated but conceptually they're
quite easy to understand right up one
complete
drink this
okay tensorflow
mobile net and I'm fine I was giving a
workshop six months ago in London and I
was actually wearing this t-shirt which
says puppies yeah and I'm fine so I see
has a long story behind it I'm not gonna
explain it but I was basically wearing
this t-shirt and then one of the
students in the workshop later on made
this demo tensorflow mobile met and I'm
fine and then sent it out I thought was
a pretty cool demo and I'm going to talk
about how how it works so it's just you
can run it in code pen or I don't think
I provided the link maybe stop there I
send the slides I'll let it run oh
you've got AI Jess rocks and find it so
it's a pretty simple demo it basically
makes it does a search on puppies on
unsplash gets an image and then all you
can't retell can you then tries to guess
what's in the image so then it's gonna
do um I'm fine which is come on okay dog
terrier okay nine percent all right so
it's not the best okay it's not the best
but there's an important takeaway from
this is the only API request is being
made here is to unsplash the detection
of what's in the image is all happening
on the client side in the browser okay
it's using something a technology called
tensorflow
Zen be here heard of tensorflow anybody
use tensorflow Oh a few there are
actually some machine learning engineers
here excellent
so tensorflow is tall does open source
by google in 2015 i think like kind of
scaled that mathematical operations but
it's used a large parts used it's used
mainly for machine
unless you scale out calculations across
GPUs and across hundreds of servers yeah
but it's built in see it's pretty heavy
way it's kind of something you have to
install last year the tens flow dev
summit they released ten so J yes that's
the important one for this conference is
that dot J S at the end of it okay I've
been poor thing about ten slow j s first
when I first heard about this I thought
tensorflow J yes was bindings to ten
supply I thought you had to install
tensor flow to use tensorflow J s that's
not true j s is a complete rewrite of
tensor flow in JavaScript completely
right what does that mean it means this
it means if all you need to do in order
to use tensor flow in JavaScript is well
if you proper do this and if you still
like me and bit old-school using script
tags you like that okay but that's all
you need to do is import one JavaScript
file and you can do machine learning it
can do a bunch of different things you
can do what I showed you just before
where I showed you the neuron Network
and the back propagation and the tuning
and all of that stuff it can do that
with an API but can also do something
else
it can load pre-trained models higher
gets interesting pre-trained models
that's what we like all right we just
like to import stuff not write stuff
that's what we do so the load
pre-trained model that there's an
ecosystem forming of like three chain
models that you can just plug plug into
your applications and if you go to TF j
s models I think research that on Google
you'll you'll find a bunch of them and
that's it you know you can train a model
and then once the models trained you can
save as a JSON file and then you can use
it here and you can even if you're using
other libraries to do machine learning
you can export them in a format and then
convert into format which x / GS likes
and users write one of the models is
called mobile net and mobile net is some
thing that has been trained in order to
detect one of a thousand it contains
like a thousand different things in the
world just a thousand that's why it was
that Bob party person or the states not
very good right but it's very small
enough mobile to be able to reasonably
be downloaded hmm in the browser okay
still free large but it's it's it's a
lot less larger lot less larger than the
other ones
but you saw so that's what he used he
used mobile net to build this
application okay he's no on that you you
wouldn't really use mobile net to do
real image analysis is its excuse for
something else like chance for learning
and a bunch of other things we don't
have time to go into today okay but what
if you want to do some really more
in-depth meaningful image analysis the
model will be too large download your
browser you have to do something else
such as the azure computer vision API
there she is again
fantastic so no Sarah Dresner fantastic
so my colleague Sarah built another demo
using the computer vision API last year
her thoughts was can you accessibility
can you automatically create alt text
for images in your applications just by
calling the computer sending the image
that computer vision API one of the
things that the API does it tells you a
textual description of what's in the
image use that as the alt tag and that's
what you did again it's a code pen you
can have a look at it you can upload
whatever image that you want so she did
this one and the API gives you a whole
bunch of information but it gave you
this text at the tops is a black and
white photo of Thomas Edison the text
says hey girl do just share electrons
because I'm feeling a covalent bond I
don't gotta know is that funny I don't
know
laughs I don't know that sounds like
sounds like it's funny the thing that I
thought was amazing about this is a
black my foe of not just a guy but
Thomas Edison right
anok and they also detected the text
from the image right that's pretty
insane right it's doing a lot of really
intense cool stuff but even this API
gets wrong sometimes as very helpful
people on Twitter you know Twitter
there's always some very helpful people
on Twitter you give some really good
advice after you post something on there
so after they put and I hope some
hopefully this is one of one of you in
the audience but after she posted this
on Twitter there a couple of people came
out and they know a lot know that there
are some issues so this one it says the
images a star-filled sky the textes four
and some some Chinese Chinese sign okay
so it didn't work there the next looks
why I think could actually be true the
next one
I mean you don't know right I mean those
could be dead stuffed animals for you
for all you know okay
and I really like the next one I think I
think the next one we've got I think 50
percent correct I don't do too well at
school so 50 percent for me is passed
see so you know sometimes just to
summarize there and I think if this
won't take away you should remember from
this talk this is the take away okay
tensorflow Jase doesn't have any
dependencies if you want to start doing
machine learning in javascript in the
browser you can just drop that in little
caveat is the node.js version and does
have dependencies but anyway
the browser-based version doesn't have
any dependencies if you want to get
started when I when I when I teach
machine learning I always start off with
nub on that just learning a model using
it's very very very easy way to kind of
step into it but it doesn't really teach
you a lot it's not it's not super useful
on its own so if you wanna do something
a much more complicated user computer
vision API we've got one called a vision
API did I tell you I work in the azure
team did you guess let me guess
okay so last demo my favorite demo
image image okay let's watch it this is
all running in the browser okay so you
can draw the outline of a cat and it
will fill in the rest of the cat
mind-blowing right mind-blowing and this
uses an algorithm called a technique
called picks - picks which is it's using
in your network and it's using something
called a generative adversarial you said
that you said that you said that you get
a sticker thank you a generative
adversarial neural network and these are
fascinating I think it's only about two
three years is the technique has become
known I think they're fascinating so
they work and this is why I taught you
neural networks so you can get to this
point they have two neural networks that
are competing with each other
adversarial one is called the generator
and one is called the discriminator okay
the generators job is given some input
some input let's say the outline some
images which have are just the outlines
of cats it's job is to generate pictures
of cats but remember you would have just
initialized them with random numbers so
it's not going to do a very good job of
generating chemita this just got me
noise okay okay you take all of your
outline of cat images you generate you
all your crappy cat images and you get
them all together and you send them all
to the discriminator which then also has
real images of cats okay so the input to
the discriminator is going to be given a
mixture of your generated cats and real
cats and the discriminators job it to be
able to detect the difference its job is
to say this is a real damage this
generated cat image and let's say it got
it wrong
because it's gonna go wrong it's
randomized it's just a random number
that's not it doesn't know what it's
doing it's probably gonna get wrong and
when it gets it wrong we have that lost
function and then we do that back
propagation and we reach unit and we
make it better and better and better and
it's gonna get better and better
discriminating if it got it right though
then well then the generators not doing
good job right and a generator gets
tuned until generator makes better and
better so as the discriminator gets
better so generator gets better
discriminates it gets better generates
gets better and we're competing with
each other until you reach a point where
the discriminator just can't tell
anymore between the Rilke images and the
fake damages okay and then what you do
this stuff you don't run this in the
browser this is incredibly compute
intensive you get rid of the
discriminate we don't care about that
you take the generator you export it
into some form of the tensor flow Jess
likes which is Bob the tense Affairs
format and then you load that into your
browser with density F dot load model
and essentially you can run this in the
browser and that's exactly what he was
doing oh I forgot to introduce the guy
he made it ziad he was still a student
at university what was I doing
University not much so that's what you
can do so he's managed to get this model
small enough I think the smallest model
he's got it's still 15 megabytes still
pretty large but still pretty impressive
he's got it working in the browser all
right
why who cares it's just a cat images who
gives yeah who gives a crap about cat
images right let's take a look at this
all right the image on the left is the
input the image on the right is the
output okay
input output this is computer-generated
computer-generated cajones but this
isn't the pics to pix algorithm this is
the bits of it algorithm
yeah this doesn't work in the browser
yet yet how about this one
one input multiple outputs
the input doesn't have to be outlines
the input can be whatever you want it to
be whatever you want it to be okay so
this is another import all the segmented
image so that this is the input this is
the output the import like because it's
segmented you know kind of like a depth
knowledge you know a little bit more
about what's going on in the image again
this is the input this is the output
okay she's not dancing dancing image is
generated as I said the input doesn't he
doesn't even have to be an image the
input can be anything anything at all
the input can be text the input can be
text I think you can read that the top
that's the import that you entered in a
description of the image that you wanted
the flower has long thing thin yellow
petals and a lot of yellow anthers in
the center the first image is 600
iterations the second image is 1,200
iterations he can't tell with the
resolution here but that second images
are very good very very good very high
definition then we've got another one
here the bird is white black and brown
in color or the brown beak and this one
was actually a bit weird but the rest of
them pretty good representations of
images
I think of eight years ago we were
unable to tell the difference in image
between a cat and a dog I think that's
all we were eight years ago this is what
we are now how long do you think it will
take before someone just types in an
e-commerce website blue theme a contact
form and about page go who cares if it's
react or Savelle or I'm sorry
or or anger who cares right it's just
would make me a website how far how long
will wait you think we are from that
[Music]
[Laughter]
just in summary this one so Ganz learn
to generate new images and that's what's
cool if it's a generative they generate
things that's what's so cool about them
previous like other types and your
network algorithms but to tell you if
something is one thing or the other Ganz
generate things they take a lot of
compute to train a lot of computer train
but the generated model generator you
can optimize it so it can be used inside
the browser with tensorflow jeaious if
you want to learn a little bit more I
want to get introduced to how to build
if you throw a little bit into machine
learning ok yes with APs but you can go
to aks mmog fire and I have instructions
I'll teach you how to build a slack bot
and you can do all whole / modify and
detect emotion and all sort of stuff if
you want to figure that out
thank you very much for your time please
follow me on Twitter